[Music]
well for many years Ed's buck has been a
big-time fundraiser in the state of
California for the Democratic Party
there he is with Hillary Clinton she
probably met him between visits to
Jeffrey Epstein and Harvey Weinstein
turns out when buck wasn't donating to
the Democrats he'd like to inject young
men with narcotics in his living room he
didn't always do a very good job
since 2017 to separate men have died of
overdoses inside Bucks West Hollywood
home here's the amazing part
authorities looked at that and shrugged
it buck faced no charges for either
death now he apparently has gone too far
this month a third man overdosed inside
Edie Bucks home by the way all of this
was in the news everyone knew that
Edie buck was injecting young people
with narcotics and no one did anything
the third OD thank God survived
yesterday authorities finally arrested
buck and accused him of what again
everyone knew he was doing luring young
men to his home in injecting them with
deadly amounts of methamphetamine so
they've charged him finally with what
everyone knew he was doing for years
because they already knew from Epstein
and Weinstein when you're a top
Democratic donor you often don't face
any consequences for your actions
how's that for corrupt